welcome to this video playing my way yes
I don't know I have a terrible at sky
and the sky I really have no idea why
that is normally tend to have good
positions but screw them up I always
place a lien on theoretical openings
like this year the Budapest Black is
just substantially worse am but yeah
this is a tough customer somehow
covering g4 maybe I should have started
with Quincy too actually so what is this
idea will be five what exactly is the
point
yeah might be
okay let's gain some space here with
beef or maybe okay so if i take it 93 m
okay i have to play of f1 can you take
and Bishop g5 or something like that
that looks really wacky
okay Gina I can't come on let's take it
not spend spend hours on that we had
stuff we had stuff and the night on f4
doesn't have many squares after g3 it
can just about take on age three but
that's it
yeah that looks kind of kind of tricky
for black to play so it's there a direct
way for me to use the exposed 29
position the bishop c1 something like
that it's directly playing in the center
so is supporting the night a bit
I take the pawn will take 22 yeah
seaking rook see one gives me another
temple the Queen has to still keep an
eye on the night I just wonder if d for
some coming at some point
I mean 28 is there something else 26
something like that that looks that
looks really loose
but still if he go screen d6 what am I
going to do is g3 already on I mean he
doesn't have many squares night takes
age 3 King age two and the night is
without a doubt squares yeah it might be
possible actually g3 night takes King
edge to d4 is the only possible way yeah
I don't know there's some some kind of
trick hitting me then I don't see it may
be overlooking something I don't know
night ashley king edge to Ida destruct
maybe deform there is maybe there is
some idea associated with deform but I
think I wanted to go just 91
94 maybe something like that 94 is in
fact interesting I mean not in at the
moment I can t care for but I think
night h rechecking King age 294 might be
might be possible if he goes to d5 I
just take the default part I think I ok
and it's got night night before
okay it takes Bishop takes Queen d3
Bishop see one Bishop see one that's
that's just nice ride with two bishops
two bishops form the rook or whatever
that is if I take on d4 Knight III may
be okay Knight to f4 is a bit with
inconvenient a convenient to face I
don't want to give up the bishop really
don't
maybe I have to ride I didn't see
another didn't see an alternative
at least this Knight c3 move allows me
to activate the night quickly getting it
here and is this good let's put it on g3
now I can take it okay look you're one
I don't know can keep that idea I can
he's on he's on five seconds only only
now saw that I'm going to probably be no
time in any case time morning black it's
I could have taken the rook I just see
okay yeah AG took took a very long time
now that was kind of a kind of weird
weird sequence this thing here it really
should be a good position the night only
for is kind of it is almost strand at
this piece of sorry before back back to
boutiques and all the computer wants to
go look ft1 nokia
ng3 immediately was possible but I
thought I should just win this his tempo
and this this and now okay he could have
done what I said yeah the the night
takes this this took a minute and was
not good Jack this this thing I just I
only saw it basically when it was played
how is in fact pretty good for me but
this is a move this is the line given by
stockfish check and it assesses this as
zeros usual probably some kind of
Perpetual oh wow okay so he played this
one this computer says so this is about
equal kind of surprised i would I
thought that this should be quite good
for me actually two bishops against the
rook and pawn okay i have the somewhat
okay now the computer evaluation keeps
climbing but it should this should be
really nice right I Bishop f4 was
stronger yeah I was just thinking about
activating activating this yeah by now
it was kind of irrelevant for the for
the game as it for the result of the
game as he was going to overstep the
time anyway it will interesting game
thanks for watching